Okay. So, um starting from usual road
map, uh last uh last Monday we started
talking about uh more modern approaches
to learning based control. specific
specifically we looked at imitation
learning as our um specific paradigm of
interest where you know loosely speaking
we uh pitched imitation learning as this
idea of wanting to learn from
demonstrations. Uh and so we saw
different types of ways of doing this
specifically behavioral cloning and
inverse reinforcement learning where the
idea there is do we want to directly
learn a policy that represents or mimics
and approximates the behavior of our
expert or do we want to learn the
objective that is the underlying reward
function that the expert is uh
optimizing. However, we also recognized
how imitation learning techniques at
their core are essentially uh kind of
capped in terms of performance by the
performance of the expert
demonstrations. And so for today and for
the rest of this uh class we move
towards uh reinforcement learning which
on the other hand is this idea of
wanting to learn from demon from
interactions um as a basically paradigm
to um learn through trial and error and
discover uh solutions for optimal
control problems. So today uh and for
the next uh two classes we'll be looking
at uh model free reinforcement learning
and then we'll be looking at model based
uh reinforcement learning.
And specifically for today, we'll start
with a brief recap of the reinforcement
learning problem setting and we'll dive
a little bit deeper into what I'm
referring to here as exact methods. So
if you recall in our lectures on dynamic
programming, we discussed value
iteration and policy iterations at ways
of solving markup decision processes.
And so we'll look a little bit more
closely on uh on those. Uh there is that
is methods that leverage dynamic
programming for uh computing solutions.
The reason why I refer to them as exact
methods is because implicitly these
methods that is valid iteration and
policy iteration were leveraging the
fact that we knew the underlying
dynamics of our system uh which is
something that on the other hand we
assume we won't have throughout
reinforcement learning and this is where
learning from interaction will come uh
will come in place and so from that
we'll then leverage and kind of build
upon those techniques to introduce two I
would say really fundamental uh kind
approaches for model free learning that
is model learning from interactions.
Specifically, we'll look at Monte Carlo
learning and temporal distance learning.
And then we will wrap up the discussion
with some kind of concluding remarks and
kind of as a segue into the next few
lectures where I'll be diving more
closely into specific algorithms both
model free and model based. [snorts]
And so starting from our um problem
setting, we introduced uh in the past
kind of this idea of a mark of decision
process which where ultimately an MDP is
represented by a quintuple of elements
here defined by the calligraphic M.
Loosely speaking, we have an action and
a state space which represent the
possible set of states and actions our
agent um could either be in or could uh
enact. We have a transition function
which is represented in the RL
literature usually as a distribution
over next states given states and
controls. We have a reward function
which maps states and controls to a
scalar measure of success. And we have a
discount factor which is just a scalar
between zero and one. We discussed this
how this is both uh useful as an from an
intuitive standpoint. It kind of trades
off long-term reward with respect to
short-term reward but also as a
mathematical object that enables an
infinite sum to become tractable.
Where does this infinite sum come in
place? It comes in place from the
overall goal that we want to um maximize
in when we talk about markup decision
processes. That is we want to find the
optimal policy pi star that maximizes
the expected cumulative discounted
rewards over time.
And to solve these problems last time we
introduced the concepts of value
functions and Bellman equations.
Specifically, we introduced the state
value function represented as V as
essentially an element that encodes uh
kind of the expected reward that we can
expect to have starting from some state
XT and then following a given policy pi.
So the value function is an object that
depends on a policy.
Um and we saw how these value functions
satisfied some fixed fixed point
equations, namely the Bellman equations.
And so we discussed the Bellman
optimality equation which is uh which
relates with the optimal value function
v star which essentially says that the
optimal value function v star at some
state xt is essentially equal to the
maximization over controls u ut of the
sum of the instantaneous reward plus the
expected um value of the next state uh
xt + one where the expectation is
essentially averaging out over possible
next
We saw how this is a property of the
optimal value function. But we discussed
this how a similar fixed point equation
holds also for any policy pi. Uh where
the very similarly this fixed point
equation that is the bellman expectation
equations is defined as we introduced
also a couple weeks back.
We did a a very similar discussion for
the Q function that is um essentially a
measure to represent our expected future
reward starting from some state XT
taking an action UT and then following a
given policy pipe. Again very similarly
here we have some fixed points equations
which these um concepts satisfy which
are namely the Bellman optimality
equation and expectation equation for
the Q function respectively.
Why did we introduce the Q function? We
introduced it because from the control
from the perspective of developing an
optimal policy. Uh this is uh pretty
useful in practice because it allows us
to define a policy implicitly through
the uh Q function as the argax over u of
the Q function defined on some state X.
uh and so very practically at least for
the perspective of uh tabular methods
that is the one we'll be looking at
today so where we don't discuss function
approximation I think it's usual to
visualize value functions both state
value functions and Q functions as just
look at tables so the value function v
of x you can namely visualize it as the
value for any specific state x1 to xn
assuming we have n possible states
And very similarly for the Q function,
this would then be a matrix representing
possible Q values for all states and all
controls.
Okay, so we said how these were
essentially interesting properties that
derived from this infinite horizon
markup decision process uh problem
setting. Um and we then operationalize
these concepts into practical algorithms
specifically through uh as we were
saying before value iteration and policy
iteration and in these algorithms they
essentially boil down if you remember at
uh as mechanisms where we iteratively
enforced these fixed points equations
until convergence. So in value iteration
we recursively enforce the Bellman
optimality equation until we converge to
the optimal value function. And for
policy iteration we alternated between a
step which we call a policy evaluation
step that is the application of the
Bellman expectation equation as we're
trying to estimate the value of a given
policy and then we had a policy
improvement step which turned out to be
a greedy policy improvement in our case.
So long story short, we have seen all of
these objects before and in the past we
derived actionable algorithms to solve
macro decision processes by uh basically
enforcing these Bellman equations. But
in order to do this we always leveraged
uh the knowledge of the dynamics
function.
So looking a little bit more closely at
policy iteration because this will be a
concept we'll be building on uh today.
If you recall policy iteration is
essentially an iterative algorithm where
we are given an initial policy pi and
for every iteration k that ranges from
one until some convergence or
termination criteria is met. We're
basically alternating between these two
processes which visually we could
visualize here on this slide. We have a
given uh initial guess for our value
function and a given initial policy. And
we alternate between the policy
evaluation step which basically
evaluates the value function for that
policy. And then we have a policy
improvement step which on the other hand
uses the um most recent estimate of the
value function to derive a better policy
from that.
How did these two processes look in
practice? For the policy evaluation
step, we recursively enforce the Balman
expectation equation as we defined
before. And for the policy improvement
step, we're basically taking the arg max
over u.
Yeah. So note again that in both of
these formulations, we're leveraging the
fact that we have the knowledge of the
dynamics function.
So more uh concretely let us look at how
this looks imple from an implementation
perspective in practice. Let's consider
this grid world example where we have um
this basically 16 dimensional um world
where we could be in either of these
grid cells.
We have 14 non- terminal states that is
the white cells and we have two terminal
states or goal states that we want to
reach. So loosely speaking, the goal
here is we'll be spawned in any of these
uh cells and the goal is to get to the
goal uh terminal cells as fast as
possible.
How do we encode this objective of
getting to the goal point as fast as
possible? An idea could be to just fix
the reward to be minus one or any
negative number uh until we reach the
terminal set, the terminal uh cell.
In this case, we're assuming we can take
kind of these four possible controls. So
the four calder directions and if we
take some of a control that would lead
us out of this grid cell, we just stay
where we are. We're doing this
assumption.
And for simplicity of calculation, we
are assuming that we have an
undiscounted MDP. So where gamma is
equal to one.
So in practice, let us take like a first
uh step in the policy iteration
algorithm, right? So we say that we have
a given initial policy and for now for
simplicity since we have potentially no
clue about what a good policy is we just
assume that our policy is a random
policy. So in all states we just take a
random action with equal probability.
Again we have potentially no clue of how
to initialize the value function. So we
might just initialize it as all zeros.
So here on the left column you're
basically seeing different iterations of
uh the policy evaluation uh step. So we
are enforcing the Bellman expectation
equations uh at k= 1 k= 2 until we
converge.
So concretely say we are at this grid
cell over here. So the two the
coordinate 22
what we're doing is that we're updating
the
value um at that specific state
as the
um
the current estimate of our value
function.
So the the reward sorry plus the
uh expected um future values uh in the
in the next states that we would expect
to be in. So for uh more formally we
have this negative one which is just the
reward of taking one step and then we
have the expectation of all possible
next states which in our case are
equally distributed around the four
possible neighboring states. So we'll be
looking at xt + one
in
uh one two
2 1
3 2
and 2 3
right so we are looking at wanting to
update this cell over here. So the
reward of taking any move is it's minus
one. Um and then we have to take the
expected value of the next of the next
state that we land in which is in our
case one of these four states
and where we take the expectation under
our transition dynamics.
This probability of being XT + one given
XT
and the action that we would take in XT
times the value
uh the previous estimate of the value
function. So this is v1 if you wish and
this would be v 0
in that state
>> right. So here nothing too fancy I just
basically formalized what we are writing
uh the the bellman expectation equation.
Yes.
>> Is it kind of just convention that at k
equals 0 you have all zeros rather than
just initializing with the value or
rather with the reward for each state.
>> Uh there is just a choice. So if you
have knowledge in in general knowledge
in your problem that you wish to um
encode as a starting point then it's
definitely a good idea to do so because
it just speeds up the convergence. But
in this case we just assume we have no
knowledge whatsoever and we start from
all zeros.
So in this case um well we know that our
previous guess was all zeros. So this is
always zero. In theory we would know
that this is you know equally
distributed across our four steps. So
this would be always 25. But in general
since we have a zero term here this
cancels out. And so for all the grid
cells in k= 1 we would actually get
minus one.
And you can then imagine that if we
repeat this process across iterations we
basically get an evolving surface of our
value function.
And if we do this until convergence we
would then get something that looks like
this.
So at this point in our algorithm
essentially we have taken kind of again
visualizing it here in our sketch. We
basically took one step in the policy
valuation step right. So we concluded a
full policy evaluation step where given
a policy we estimated the value for that
policy.
What is the next step then here?
according to the policy iteration
algorithm.
>> Yes,
>> we want to use those expected values to
derive a different policy.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, we want to then take
basically do this step which is the
policy improvement step. How did we
define it so far? We basically take this
arg max over this quantity over here,
right?
And which essentially means that the
say that we converge to this value
function over here. The policy that
maximizes this value function since the
reward is always minus one. No matter
what we do, the policy will basically
converge to taking the action u which
leads to the best uh the state with the
best value function value. Right? So
from here we could immediat like even
visually see that in each of these grid
cells we're basically the the policy
that we get from that policy improvement
step essentially would be pointing
towards the state with the the
neighboring state with the best value
function
which is exactly what we get here. So
this would be the visualiz visualization
of the policy that we get out of the
policy improvement step from this value
function which we estimated before.
Now of course um we if you kind of in
general we uh run a full policy
evaluation step until convergence in
this case but you can always hypothesize
doing the policy improvement step at
intermediate steps in our policy
evaluation iterations. Right? In this
case since this is a very simple problem
you would actually get the optimal
policy even if you stopped before
convergence. But this is not guaranteed
to be the case in general.
For example, here, right? If we stopped
immediately and did a policy improvement
step here, we will get a policy that is
still slightly better from the original
one because we do get some nice behavior
here where we're not random random
anymore, but still not not there yet.
>> Yes. is
not have sorry is a is a stationary
policy enough of a signal to say that
you've converged or is it possible that
between iterations you could have the
policy not change but that if you
continue and the value function
continues changing you then might update
policy later on
>> yeah so in general like I guess the
question is how do you define
termination criteria for this case so in
general for these tabular settings where
we can actually enumerate all the
possible value functions uh so values
for each states and each state action
pairs. This is proven to converge. So
there is no like if you run this long
enough you will be converging. In
general there are different types of
termination criteria you could come up
with. Some could be like u delta based
so depending on how much it changes
across iterations and there is no real
kind of one best rule for doing that if
that makes sense. So to answer to your
question in this case as long as you run
it long enough you will be converging to
the optimal uh value function and
policy.
Okay. And so you will notice also
running through this example that all of
these formulations uh in this case we
looked at policy iteration but the same
thing holds for value iteration. All of
these formulations require a model of
the MDP. So we use the transition
dynamics to update uh our quantities
in general to solve unknown NDPs that is
NDPs where um we don't have access to
the ground truth transition dynamics
will use interactions with the
environment to replace this knowledge
and so more generally speaking we kind
of the main limitations of these exact
methods such as polit policy and value
iterations are uh mainly two. The first
one is that the update equations require
access to the dynamics and we'll use
sampling based approximations to uh
basically um solve and address this
challenge and we'll see this more
shortly. And the other one is that kind
of iteration over and storage of all of
the states and actions and the values
for the states and actions can require
uh extreme kind of a large memory effort
and also it could just lead to very long
uh kind of far away convergence for
these algorithms. And so um whenever we
have a very large state action space
we'll see how function approximation
could comes in handy. Today we'll be
mostly looking at sampling base
approximations but starting from uh next
week we'll also be looking at function
approximations.
Okay, any questions here before we get
started with the um with the first
algorithms.
Okay,
so let's start from uh Monte Carlo
learning and the idea of Monte Carlo is
actually u extremely simple. So
we're saying that we are interested in
estimating these values for uh value
functions in general
and
we want to do this using samples. What
do we mean with samples in our case? So
we have an environment which we assume
we can interact with and interactions
essentially means collecting rollouts
right. So we'll be releasing our policy
in the environment and collecting the
rollouts that we get from the
environment right. So this means
collecting a sequence of states and
controls over time until we reach some
uh termination criteria here.
Now in principle the what we are
interested in when we talk about in this
case for example the value of state x1
would be to basically approximate the
expected future rewards that would
expect to have um if we were able to
simulate infinitely many scenarios right
I'm interested in the ground truth
expectation of this uh value function
to do to do this so Far we've leveraged
knowledge of the uh transition dynamics
but in general this is not possible
right. So we want to do this through
sampling and this means in that in Monte
Carlo what we do is that we basically
want to approximate this um expected um
expected value function or expected
future reward through the return. The
return for us, let's remember that it's
just the or the return of a trajectory
in this case at time t is just the sum
of all the rewards that we observed from
time t onwards.
Again, simply put, the return starting
from X1 would just be having our
trajectory, evaluating all of the
rewards that we got over time, and
summing them up.
And the idea is that if we were to
repeat this multiple times, so we don't
have only one trajectory, but we have
multiple, we would be essentially able
to approximate this ground truth
expectation that we're interested in
through the mean, the empirical mean
essentially.
Does this make sense?
Yes. And so be because of this
essentially Monte Carlo methods are
methods that directly learn from
episodes of experience and it is model
free. Right. So so there is no knowledge
of the transitions that we're using
here. We're just using interactions or
samples from our environment to
approximate these values.
One caveat of course which is also a
pretty important one is that because of
how we define the return which is
literally the sum of all the rewards
that we observe throughout our
trajectory uh Monte Carlo methods um
apply only to episodic MDP MDPs. So we
there needs to be a termination of our
episode at some point simply because
otherwise we will be continuing to
summing uh summing up rewards forever
essentially.
So how do we use this in practice?
Kind of uh an immediate thought there
would be to use Monte Carlo methods for
learning the state value function B.
Right? So recall that we defined the uh
return as just the discounted sum of
future rewards from given a trajectory.
In principle, we're interested in
approximating this expectation here,
which is just our value function. So for
us, the value function is the expected
future reward um that I expect to have
starting in in XT following a policy pi.
And if you look at this inner term here,
this is nothing else than the return
itself,
right? So the the entire so the
definition of the value function is
actually the expectation of the return
given uh state xt.
[snorts]
And so with Monte Carlo methods we
essentially or specifically with Monte
Carlo policy evaluation what we would be
doing is that we use the empirical mean
to estimate this expectation um instead
of computing exactly this expectation
through the knowledge of the dynamics.
Okay, in practice you could have two
variants of um Monte Carlo methods. The
first is referred to as first visit
Monte Carlo where in order to evaluate
the value function at a given state,
we would be essentially computing these
means these mean returns uh only the
first time we visit a specific state in
an episode.
So in practice once we visit a specific
state x we would be incrementing the
counter of how many times we visited
that state x. we would be incrementing
the total return. So that is all the
returns that we ever saw when visiting
that state x and then just taking the
mean.
And in general the assuming we have you
know the more samples of this trajectory
we would have. So with n going to
infinity we would be converging to the
ground truth uh expectation.
The other approach is the every visit
approach where now we account explicitly
for the situation where maybe within our
rollout for some reason we are maybe
visiting kind of state x1 again right so
we are maybe doing taking some some
detour and we end up in the starting
state again in the first visit we would
basically be ignoring the return from
the second visit onwards in the every
visit we just consider these two as
independent visits and update the mean
regardless.
Again, this is just a kind of
technicality when you look at
implementation, but the overall idea is
that we want to approximate these um
expected future rewards because we
cannot uh compute these expectations
exactly. We approximate them through an
empirical mean.
>> Yes.
same state from different trajectories.
Isn't it wouldn't wouldn't it be I don't
know unfair the right word but to
exclude that from your database with the
first visit um mentality rather than
doing the every visit mentality.
>> Yes, I think it's a valid point
especially if you have these um maybe
the generate cases where you know the
policy is visiting the state over and
over. Um
I would say in general this probably
boils down to
you want to have sufficient
exploration right so you want the policy
that basically explores your state space
state action space uh well enough uh for
uh for these tools to be efficient and
effective in practice. Um but yes so
when you have these cases you know it is
a valid uh discussion to consider like
should I go for an every visit example
or a first visit case maybe in that case
the the first visit is is what you want
>> like explain an example like in practice
like you don't if you're not able to run
this and collect this data on
simulations based on some model that you
have like wouldn't be difficult in
practice to set up some experiment and
collect all this data.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, this is a good question because in
general so here when we talk about model
free we refer to the fact that we're not
leveraging a known model of the dynamics
uh within our calculations. Now you
could indirectly use it by having
interactions with the simulator. Uh but
in general here this is agnostic to any
kind of uh kind of environment and
reality we are interacting with. Right?
So by model free here we just mean that
we are modifying all of our update
equations say in the policy iteration
case to avoid using an an analytical
expression of the transition dynamics.
So uh in practice I would say leveraging
a simulator here would be a concrete
example of using this. So we have some
simulator that simulates our uh
environment, say a driving simulator,
and then we want to use these tools to
estimate a value function within that
simulated word. But we're doing this
without leveraging the potentially
extremely complex model that runs under
the hood in the simulation. If that
makes sense.
Yes. Does it does it clarify?
Yeah. Yeah. So bottom line is model free
here just refers to the fact that we're
not using the transition dynamics.
Okay. So um let's look at uh an example.
So here consider the game of of
blackjack which we're probably most of
us are familiar with it. But in general
kind of here we are assuming that we
have um uh you know a state where we
have you know we are dealt two cards.
We're playing against the dealer that
also has two cards. Um the state for us
is that we are considering the current
sum of the two cards that we have in
hand that ranges from 12 to 21.
We are also um specifically uh
recognizing if the dealers showing uh
the dealer showing card. So we are have
visibility of one of the two cards of
the dealer. So from ace to 10 and we are
specifically having a flag if we have a
usable ace or not. So we do do we have
an ace in hand or not.
In this case of course the goal is to um
beat the sum of the dealer essentially
having the the hand that reaches closer
to 21.
The way we do this is by so we have two
possible actions right. So at any point
in time either we stand so we stop
receiving cards and the goal the game
terminates or we hit that is we ask for
another card without replacement.
In this case the reward for us is that
when we stand so where the game
terminates we get a plus one rewards if
we if our sum of the cards essentially
beats the one of the dealer. We have
zero if we have a tie and we have a
negative reward if our if we are uh if
we lose against the dealer for the hit
we when we actually ask for another
cards we get a negative reward if we go
above 21 or the game terminates and we
get zero otherwise.
So we in general the we are assuming
that we automatically hit if our sum of
cards is uh below 12. This is the only
assumption that we have on the
transitions. So in this case we want to
consider a given policy. So we are given
to us this policy which basically stands
if the sum is greater or equal than 20
and always hits otherwise. And so the
goal here is let's now take this
environment with these rules and
basically run policy evaluation through
Monte Carlo sampling in this
environment.
Is the setting here? Nice.
So we'll be blackjack experts after this
I guess. [snorts] Um so the so the what
we're looking at here is assume we are
running policy evaluation for
10,000 episodes or uh 500,000 episodes.
So again here what we're saying this
would be one episode of interaction.
We're assuming we are playing 10,000 and
500,000 uh games with the dealer.
And these kind of uh three-dimensional
landscapes are essentially a
visualization of the value function. So
here specifically we have two axes. One
axis is looking at the um dealer showing
card that ranges from an ace to a 10. We
have a player sum. So the sum that we
have in hand from 12 to 21. And we have
this surface
uh kind of bit differentiated between
when we have a usable ACE and when we
don't have a usable ACE. So this is just
our state space, right? If you remember
those three uh bullet points.
So what we see is first of all um you
see a difference between the column that
relates with the 10,000 episodes and the
500,000 episodes in terms of noise,
right? So these estimates are definitely
more noisy than the ones where we have
more um uh more episodes. Again the
reality is that here we are
approximating these expectations through
empirical means. And so the more
episodes we have the more we are
converging to uh the ground truth
solution.
And to basically maybe understand to to
to get your understanding here let us
look at some some questions and some
questions for you. So consider the
specifically the diagrams on the right.
So why does the estimated value function
jump up for the last two rows uh here in
the back?
>> Yeah.
>> 20 and 21. We always hit until we get
there. Either most of the time we're in
a buff, but if we do get there, we're
probably going to win. [clears throat]
>> Yeah, exactly. So, we are, you know,
we're playing a game with our policy
that is given to us where we only stand
if you're 2021. And if we do, you know,
that's a pretty good hand. So, we likely
win.
So, exactly correct. And another
question could be why does the why does
it drop why does the value function drop
off for the whole last row on on the
left on the other hand
>> depends when the dealer has an ace
>> so they're likely to have a 10 to get
>> exactly so or also just uh you know
having an ace is is is a good hand right
so you can use the ace in different ways
and so that's on average is something
where the dealer is is well positioned.
So in general of course you see how kind
of the bottom line here is that
in policy valuation we basically had
um no information whatsoever on how the
game works or any dynamics of this game.
We basically leveraged simulation if you
wish or interactions with the
environment to uh estimate uh future
values of all the states and what we get
is through this interaction a complete
representation of the value of every
possible state that we could find
ourselves in this game. And so given
this policy that it's given to us, we
have exactly characterized um kind of
its efficacy in in all different states
if that makes sense.
And this value function is to some
extent um interpretable, right? Because
we can more or less understand it and
it's reasonable.
Okay. As a um as a just note in general
we're talking about in Monte Carlo we're
leveraging empirical means to
approximate expectations. Uh of course
uh we these episodes will be coming in
incrementally and so it doesn't make
sense to recomputee the means from
scratch or store all the possible
rewards that we ever observed. But in
practice we often uh compute the means
incrementally. And so we know that this
is you know standard result that we can
compute the mean for uh a given you know
radization x um incrementally through
this um uh equation over here where
we're essentially updating the mean as
the previous estimate plus basically a
step in the direction of the uh new
observation.
So this is in general for incremental
means. Of course, for us, the mean that
we're interested in computing is the
expected return, right? The mean return,
which for us is our estimate of the
value. And so we'll be updating our
value uh our estimate for the value
function [snorts] as the previous guess
plus basically a step in the direction
of the new return that we have observed.
So this is the exact formulation for the
incremental mean. In practice, we'll
often see this expressed uh kind of very
similarly to what you would see uh kind
of a gradient descent uh step update
rule where we could have a a varing
alpha uh basically a scaler that changes
how big of a step we're taking in the
direction of the update.
Okay, any any questions on on Monte
Carlo before we move to uh TD learning?
Okay, so Monte Carlo is one I would say
really fundamental strategy for model
free learning. TD learning is I would
say the other bigger player in when we
talk about um model free learning uh
techniques and specifically at a high
level TD learning is a combination of uh
Monte Carlo and dynamic programming
approaches. So like Monte Carlo TD
learning is model free. So there is no u
knowledge of the transition dynamics in
R&DP
and TD learning also learns from
experience right. So we are replacing
this knowledge through interactions uh
with the environment.
On the other hand, different uh kind of
differing from Monte Carlo but similarly
to dynamic programming um temporal
difference learning update estimates of
for example values based in part on
other learned estimates. Essentially um
we can update our guess towards a guess
without waiting for the final outcome in
our episodes. Uh more more formally uh
it is denoted as temporal difference
learning and dynamic programming
bootstrap.
So
remember how in
dynamic programming we were essentially
saying that we could have a recursive
um function where the value function for
us would be at a state xt would be equal
to the immediate return a reward that we
see at xt plus the discounted
um future value at the next state xt
Right
now in TD learning since we cannot appro
uh compute these expectations exactly
because in order to do this we would
have to have knowledge of our transition
dynamics. We use samples to approximate
these expectations.
So in Monte Carlo we were using the full
trajectory to directly estimate the
return.
In TD we are only interested in the
onestep update where we will be updating
the value of X1
basically as the
in the direction of the immediate reward
that we see R1 plus the discounted value
at X2 in this case.
Right? So we'll be using this same
property that we can use our current
estimate for the value function to
basically
approximate all future rewards that we
will have uh we would have observed uh
going forward with the episode.
So more concretely let us look at at the
specific definition in Monte Carlo. Um
we said that we want to update our value
estimate towards the actual return GT.
Specifically, we take a step alpha in
the direction of the return.
In temporal difference learning, we
update the value towards the estimated
return where this estimate is taken
using basically dynamic programming
ideas where we take the immediate reward
plus the discounted future estimate of
our uh of our value.
And so specifically we take a step in
the direction of this target over here
in red.
So in general uh this the reward plus a
discounted future value is referred to
as the TD target. And the uh difference
between our guess and this TD target is
known as the TDF.
So in general you see how temporal
difference methods combine the sampling
of Monte Carlo because we're only
leveraging interactions with the
environment to estimate our values with
the bootstrapping of dynamic programming
because we're updating a guess towards a
guess.
>> Yes.
>> Just quick recap for the first one with
GFT. Does that mean you'd have to run a
bunch of rollouts at each up step to
figure out what the actual return would
be? So here this is independent of how
many rollouts you do. So here we're
saying that we want to approximate the
f the actual uh uh return. So that is
the sum of all future rewards through
sampling. Specifically here we could
take one sample of the return which is
just means sampling uh sorry summing all
the rewards that we see over time.
Visually we want to approximate this
ground truth expectation over here and
we could do this by just uh evaluating
the empirical returns that we observe
over time and taking a mean.
Now GT is just the definition of the
return. And so for us assuming we have
one sample, this would be a one sample
estimate of the actual expectation.
In temporal difference learning, instead
of looking at the final return here, we
actually look at the one-step uh
estimate of that return where this
estimate is just the instantaneous
reward R1 plus the discounted uh guess
of the value here.
So in other words, our guess here is
just a mechanism to avoid having to run
through the entire episode but
approximating what this rest of the
return will be at uh time two in this
case. Does this clarify?
>> Yeah.
just like you have like
>> so in general so the interaction will
always be um
you know for full rollouts so we'll be
having full interactions with our
environment but then this is changing
how we update our value estimates in the
Monte Carlo case we update our value
estimates looking basically one episode
at a time, the full episode. In TD
learning, we can actually update our
value estimates more often because this
would basically be only one update if
that makes sense because we only have
one return.
>> Here we can update uh our value function
um before the episode finishes
potentially because we just use our our
guess to do so.
>> Yeah.
potentially potentially.
>> Yeah. So, kind of looking at differences
more uh more closely.
[snorts] Um we mentioned how Monte
Cararo learning essentially requires
episodic MDPs because we need to reach
the terminal state at the end. Uh on the
other hand, in TD learning because we
are only using our own guess to estimate
the values. Um, TD learning can learn
before the final outcome essentially.
And so TD learning can potentially learn
online after every step while Monte
Carlo must wait until the end of the
episode to collect those returns.
And so indeed Ted learning can learn
without the final outcome and so can
learn from potentially incomplete
sequences
um and can potentially work in
continuing or non-terminating
environments. But on the other hand, the
Monte Carlo requires this
discrimination.
Does this make sense?
>> Yeah. So I would say really kind of
Monte Cary learning and TD learning are
kind of the fundamental mechanisms
through which we estimate quantities of
interest. Most of the times these are
values and value functions and that
these are really kind of you know the
foundations over which all model kind of
reinforcement learning algorithms are
all built on. Either if these are
estimated you are kind of value based
methods or policy optimization methods
we will see kind of actor critic and so
forth. All of these tools essentially
rely on some approximation of value
functions and if when we don't have a
knowledge of the transition dynamics we
have to resort to interactions with that
environment and leverage tools similar
to Monte Carlo and TD learning to do so.
>> Yeah.
depend on like value function the next
step in [clears throat] like
how could that work from environments
like the way I'm understanding is like
you would have to recursively go back
from the final state to understand the
value have that final state and then
work backwards to say x
so how I think I'm misunderst
>> I think you have the right intuition
Because basically what you're saying is
uh I get that the point that we're
updating our guests towards our next
guess and how this could mechanically
work online at each step even without
relying on the final step. But you're
saying at the end of the day we need to
ground some of our estimates on an
actual value right and I think this is
correct and this is exactly where kind
of the discount factor comes into into
play because if we take the you know the
extreme version where we are you know
the [snorts] final we are at step
500,000 in the future then here kind of
the future values will essentially be
very close to zero and so we will have a
way to estimate these value functions.
So it's not exploding to infinity if
that makes sense.
Okay. But so we're basically saying
we're interested in estimating values
and value functions. Uh we introduce
these two ways of doing so. Monte Carlo
and TD learning um which are essentially
estimators of a quantity that we're
interested in in approximating right
that is the expected future reward or
the cost to go the reward to go in this
case. So let us look at kind of
properties of these two estimators right
so specifically the bias and uh variance
of these two estimators. So
let us take Monte Carlo to start.
So we're interested in estimating the
true value of our policy
and we're saying that in order to do so
we want to use the return which is just
the sum the discounted sum all the
rewards that we observe. Now, of course,
this return is an unbiased estimate of
the ground truth um value. Again, uh
kind of uh using an extreme example, if
the expectation that we're actually
interested in will be the expectation
over all possible future evolutions or
episodes in our environment and we're
and the return is just the
a sample from this. If we take an
infinite amount of um interactions and
episodes with our environment, we would
be converging to the ground truth
expectation. Right? So in this sense,
this estimator is actually an unbiased
estimate.
In principle, the true TD target that is
for temporal difference learning um is
also an unbiased estimator of the actual
value. But this is only if we assume we
already know what the true value
function is. Right? So here we're saying
we're using this value function at at
the next step to basically approximate
the future reward.
And if the value function is exact, then
this would actually be a an exact
characterization of the expected reward
to go. But in reality we won't be using
the exact the true uh value function
because this the [snorts] purpose of
learning is trying to estimate the value
function. And so we will actually be
using an estimate right kind of a v hat
for our value. And so since this
estimate won't be exact we're
introducing some bias.
Does this make sense?
Yeah.
Okay. And uh how about uh variance? So
in general
I would uh the TD target is uh a much
lower variance estimator than the true
than the return. And this is because the
return depends on a full sequence of
random actions, transitions and reward
realizations.
On the other hand, TD error, the TD
error kind of only depends on one kind
of sample uh of uh basically stoasticity
of a random action transition and
reward. Right? So here we're saying that
in order to approximate the future
reward to go, we are either
approximating through the return that we
evaluate here or we approximate it
through the
um TD uh target. So basically in this
case R1 plus V X1
right. So in in the former in the former
case in order to compute the return GT
we're basically sampling multiple times
over the episode where sampling means we
have potentially unknown kind of
stoastic transition dynamics
that we are repeatedly sampling from. we
have a potentially stoastic policy
that we're potentially sampling from and
the reward itself might be a stoastic
reward right on the other hand in the TD
for the TD error for the TD target we're
doing the same sampling but only once
right and so in this sense the return as
an estimate of the true uh value is
actually a much higher variance
estimator because there are just many
more possible futures that we are kind
of taking into consideration here.
Okay. But so let's really um kind of
drive this uh this message home and I
think it's useful to visualize this
through uh these sort of treel like
diagrams and specifically let let us
look at Monte Carlo first. So in we
basically introduced uh what is often
referred to as a Monte Carlo backup
meaning the update equation that we use
for our value estimates according to
Monte Carlo learning and we define this
as updating our guess of the value
function by taking a step in the
direction of the return.
What does this mean visually in this
diagram? uh kind of white nodes here
represent states um and black nodes
represent actions and t represents a
terminal state. So that is where the
episode terminates and so you see how
potentially in state xt we could be
taking two possible actions and
depending on the action that we take we
could land on potentially two different
states
in a Monte Carlo backup. This
essentially means that in this possible
tree of all kind of futures that we
could observe in our environment, we
approximate the ground truth expectation
of the values by essentially taking a
full episode of interactions with the
environment until we reach a terminal
condition
and using the return that we observe
over here to update our guess.
differently. In TD learning, we defined
our update as taking a step in the
direction of the immediate reward plus a
guess of our um future values.
And so this visually means that rather
than having to take a full episode of
interaction until reaching a terminal
state, we only look at the onestep
transition. If that makes sense.
On the other extreme, kind of kind of
positioning this with respect to what we
saw with dynamic programming. In dynamic
programming, we were essentially able to
evaluate exactly these expectations
through the use of the transition
dynamics, right? And so we weren't
really defining these estimates of these
expectations because we could actually
compute the exact expectation by
basically analyzing this uh basically
computing this expectation analytically
through the knowledge of the dynamics.
Any
any questions here?
Okay. So, we've seen um we've seen now
how um we introduced these two basically
techniques, right? So we discussed
sampling um as essentially our mechanism
to approximate expectations through
interactions with the environment and we
saw how both Monte Carlo and TD learning
um sample and this is because they're
model free algorithms. So we assume we
don't have knowledge to dynamics on the
other hand dynamic programming does not
sample because there we assume we had
knowled knowledge of the dynamics and we
could compute those expectations
exactly.
We then discussed also bootstrapping
where the idea is to basically update uh
our guess towards a guess right and we
saw how both uh TD learning and dynamic
programming were using this idea while
Monte Carlo did not.
And so really what we're doing uh today
is basically
constructing or paving uh a unifying
view of all possible reinforcement
learning algorithms depending on these
two axes. So uh and specifically
thinking about these um trees that we
were observing before different
algorithms fall on a spectrum depending
on the width of the backup. So we
discussed algorithms that look at the
full width of the backup that is uh
dynamic programming or intuitively also
exhaustive search right we could just
sample infinitely until we explore the
full tree or on the other hand uh
algorithms that only um sample use um at
the extreme one sample from the
environment right and so we looked at
temporal difference learning and Monte
Carlo learning similarly We looked
[clears throat] at the height of the
backup that is through on one extreme
Monte Carlo and exhaustive search
require reaching the end so a terminal
state in order to update their values
and TD learning and dynamic programming
instead relied only on a one-step um
update because they could use
bootstramping to um approximate their
values. Of course, these are just kind
of four extremes of a spectrum and you
could envision algorithms laying some
somewhere in between, right? So, for
example, you could assume having rather
than updating your um TD target after
one step, you might assume that you want
to do four steps of experience and then
uh use the value function after four
steps of experience. And there are pros
and cons when doing so.
>> [snorts]
[snorts]
>> Okay. So um let's now build towards uh
if you want a first working versions
version of a reinforcement learning
algorithm using these tools. So in
previous lectures we introduced policy
iteration and also earlier today um and
we essentially discussed how this is um
an algorithm that implements two uh
interactive processes right we have
policy evaluation on one hand which
given a policy estimates the value for
that policy and then we have policy
improvement where given a new estimate
of the value function we used it to
improve the correct policy. In general
um we will use the term generalized
policy iteration to refer to this
general idea of an algorithm skeleton or
structure whereby we we will be
iterating between these two processes
regarding of kind of regardless of how
these two processes are actually
specifically defined
in policy iteration. We saw how the
policy evaluation scheme, the policy
evaluation step was essentially
iterative enforcement of the Bman
expectation equation.
And for the policy improvement step, we
used a greedy policy improvement. Right?
So we were taking the arg max over uh
the quantity defined by the new value
function.
But this is a general formalism and you
will see how many algorithms actually
apply this uh this skeleton.
Okay, so you know we mentioned how
policy iteration specifically required
knowledge of the dynamics to in both of
these processes, right? So we use the
knowledge of the dynamics to perform
policy valuation through the Balman
expectation equation and we use the
knowledge of the dynamics to um improve
the policy in our greed improvement
step. So
can we make this actionable through
everything that we learned today? So the
first thing that you might think of is
can we replace the you know analytical
policy kind of bleman expectation
equation through Monte Carlo policy
evaluation of the value function. Right?
So the first step is we were given a
policy and we want to estimate the value
for that policy. Can we do this through
Monte Carlo policy evaluation which is
what we've done uh today.
and potentially leave unchanged greedy
policy improvement.
And the answer is that well uh yes in
the sense that Monte Carlo policy
evaluation will work and this is exactly
what we've been doing today in both uh
in the Monte Carlo learning section but
then the greedy policy improvement as we
said before relied on this knowledge of
the transition dynamics to update our
policy to take this arts right so this
will not will not cut it in a way
so kind of one thing is that so we
discussed before how the Q function is a
nice object in order to uh and a
convenient object in order to define a
policy implicitly. So let us just
replace the value function V with the Q
function.
So now we're looking at a version of
policy iteration where we are doing
Monte Carlo policy evaluation of the Q
function and then potentially greedy
improvement. So, will this work?
What do you think? Well, there is a
spoiler on the slides, of course, but
what do you think? And and why?
Well, the point is that it it won't in
general. And the idea is that here kind
of touches on I would say um a really
fundamental issue and challenge in
reinforcement learning which is the one
of um exploration. So the trade-off
between exploitation and exploration.
So we
let us look at this from the perspective
of a simple example. So say we have two
doors uh and that is and we need to pick
among these two doors and each of these
two doors will give us a specific
reward.
This is a in a way stateless environment
because we are always in in the same
state right. So we have nothing that
conditions us in in picking the two
doors. But now say that we have no
information of the quality of the two
doors and that we first of all uh so we
initialize our Q function randomly and
then al or randomly we basically pick
the left door as our first interaction
and we get a reward of zero. So we
basically update the value of our Q
function as zero.
Now we similarly uh uh kind of execute
in our environment and we pick the right
door and we observe a reward of one in
this case. So we update the value of the
Q.
Now note that in general right now the
policy that we are executing in the
environment is a deterministic policy
right it is the R max over the Q
function. So since we have basically
created the situation where the right
choice is basically dominating the left
door here and basically forever we'll
always be choosing the right door,
right? And so this is potentially
at loss of a better reward that we might
have had on the left door.
And so the problem here is once we
estimate Q functions or state action
values through samples then we need to
visit every state action pair in order
to approximate those values
and deterministic policies do not allow
for this exploration.
So a simple but effective trick uh and
strategy is to basically
uh introduce some randomness in how we
explore the environment in how we take
decisions and a simple strategy is the
one of epsilon greedy exploration
specifically
with some probability epsilon
u one minus epsilon we will be
consistent with how we've picked the
action so far so we will just take the
arg max over q on the other hand with
some small prob BD epsilon uh we will be
acting randomly. So we'll just pick a
random actions from our possible action
space.
This is a very simple trick but
fundamentally this ensures that all m
actions are tried nonzero probability
and so this on the long run ensures that
we are visiting and exploring and that
is having a nice coverage of our entire
state action space.
And so if you wish kind of this builds
and leads us to kind of a first working
version of an reinforcement learning
algorithm that is something where we
have Monte Carlo policy evaluation of a
Q function and then an epsilon greedy
policy improvement.
So since the goal for today is becoming
experts at blackjack um let's look at
how like the policy that we will get if
we run this in practice on the same
environment that we had before. So now
before we were focusing on policy
evaluation. So we were given a specific
policy that that was uh standing if the
sum of cards was 20 or above. Um now
we're actually doing the full problem
where we actually want to uh derive an
optimal policy for the for the task. And
so here kind of you know if you trust me
that by running exactly the algorithm
that we discussed so far we would
basically be converging to um this
policy over here whereby um you know we
have a specific rule that we can also
inspect where depending on if we have an
a usable ace or not and kind of the sum
of the cards and the dealer showing card
we have an explicit rule of whether we
do stick or stand or Okay.
And note maybe intuitively that um if we
don't have a usable ACE, we're actually
more conservative here, right? So, of
course, we can go into the details and
I'm definitely not advising you to try
this strategy if you if you go casinos,
but this is the this is the idea, right?
Again, we gave no clue, no intuition
whatsoever to the environment on how to
behave. And through this interaction we
derived both an optimal policy and its
respective uh value function.
Okay. So to to recap what we've been
discussing so far. So we started from u
exact methods for solving uh mark of
decision processes right namely policy
iteration and value iteration.
And we said and recognized that these
have some limitations. Specifically
today we looked at the first of these
two which is the one that in
both the update equations and in the
uh of our estimates for the value
function that is the Bellman equations
and in the greedy policy improvement
steps we were using implicitly our a
knowledge of the transition dynamics.
And so today kind of we focus on these
two main classes of methods and families
of methods MCarning and TDarning to
address this through interaction.
And so indeed so we introduce MCarning
and TD learning as examples of a
spectrum right where depending on the
height or width of the backup uh we
could derive different algorithms
all under the ma kind of shared goal of
solving unknown MDPs through learning.
We did not discuss how we could deal
with highdimensional state action spaces
uh but we'll do this in the in the
coming lectures.
Okay, any questions here before uh I
spend a few minutes on some concluding
remarks?
All right,
so if you recall last week we were
looking at this taxonomy of
reinforcement learning algorithms. Um
starting next week we'll be looking at
kind of in order uh we'll be looking at
valuebased methods. uh next Monday we'll
then be looking at policy optimization
uh next Wednesday and then we'll be
looking at uh model based uh algorithms
well not next Monday because that's bank
holiday but next next time and then
we'll be looking at uh model based
algorithms
in general
um I think it is really valuable to see
all of these algorithms as different
instantiations of a common shared
skeleton of a reinforcement learning
algorithm and specifically the skeleton
has three main uh processes going on.
The first one is that all algorithms
will have some way of generating samples
right because we want to learn from
interaction and as we saw today
interaction for us essentially means
sampling um episodes from interactions
with the environment
where the goal here will be essentially
to collect these uh trajectories or
episodes of interactions to
and use these quantities to uh basically
do something with it. Specifically,
we'll use these samples from the
environment to either fit a model or
estimate a value. Right? So, today we
discussed extensively how we might be
interested in estimating um value
functions or Q functions. Um but in
general we might also see how we could
use these um trajectories to estimate um
a learned model of our dynamics in
model. Bottom line is we will have some
interactions with that environment and
we'll be doing something with that
interaction which is loosely speaking
either estimating some values or um
fitting some model of our dynamics
and then we'll use these computations
that we do in the second block to
improve the policy. Today we saw how we
are basically using kind of an an
excellent greedy or greedy policy
improvement step but we will see
different ways of um improving the
policy.
For example, we'll see how in policy
optimization algorithms. we will be
taking um gradient steps with respect to
some parameters theta which might
represent a parametric um policy that
we're defining in the in order to
optimize the RL objective directly that
is maximize estimated return but we'll
see this uh more next week
okay but bottom line is I think this is
a um a very useful mental model to use
when approaching different arguments
because this is really a kind of other
core what most of these are doing.
Okay, so if there are no more questions,
uh I'll see you next time with value
based reinforcement learning. Thank you.